to every other day for coffee animals try to make sure my body could have all
movements on its own. Should I go back to doing it every day? I know that's a hard
choice. Some people don't like to feel like they're dependent upon doing coffee
animals. We're having all movements but I just don't know to me it's like why is
that a bad thing? The only reason why that would be a bad thing if I was in something
where I had to travel a lot, it's hard to do that. I understand that but if that's
not you, you're at home. It certainly is health-benefit wise,
aerosipinant stimulation, detoxification stimulation to do them on a daily
basis. Were there other therapies that stood out that I should try? I'm just walking
fast for exercise and it's starting to get hot again in Florida so I try to go
outside of sweat. So I think sweating is going to be your friend. I think that's
the best one of the best ways to take pressure off of your liver and your kidney is
to help remove toxins through sweating.